well from buying groceries to close to
well actually just about anything we all
shop online these days brian yeah but
how do you know when you're getting the
best deal kirsten joyce live in studio
you're here to tell us
all about how we can really be smarter
shoppers
yeah we all want to be right amazon is
the leading shopping site so many of us
rely on it for its efficiency
quick delivery but does it always have
the lowest prices
one price comparison app creator i spoke
with says that's not always the case
for many of us the ease of amazon is the
answer to a lot of our shopping needs
with the two-day delivery it's usually
in vegas about next day
i often find that amazon really is truly
better for myself just because of the
convenience a recent study we did show
that
thirds of the items you browse on amazon
have some sort of what we call a red
flag
maybe the seller is not reputable
maybe the price is too high omri traub
is the creator of an app that comparison
price tracks while a user is online
shopping he points to granola being sold
on amazon this week for 25 dollars
while it's 10 bucks cheaper on another
side and a few bucks cheaper than
amazon's at another major retailer
and this long grain rice is listed for
sale on amazon at 11 bucks and change
while it's five dollars on another site
but 18
at another major retailer lots of people
are doing this and they're known as
third-party sellers on amazon
and they're listing everyday items from
toys to shoes
and and you kind of don't know who
you're really buying from anymore
or if the price you're about to pay is
actually a good price
this past holiday season analyst firm
profitero studied more than 18 thousand
of the best selling products
and found amazon to be the lowest price
retailer with prices on average fifteen
percent lower than competitors
an amazon spokesperson tells us quote we
work hard to provide customers with low
prices
vast selection and fast delivery our
systems are designed to meet the best
available price amongst our competitors
every day so that customers don't have
to
the bottom line do your research when
you click on the item to see what's
being sold by whether it's amazon or a
third-party seller
see if your shipping costs are already
covered or not how many days it'll take
to arrive
and of course read the reviews practices
these savvy shoppers
already put into place if it's not sold
by amazon that's where i kind of
do more comparison shopping it's easier
to just
do the google shop or run to the other
website and check
another smart tip by using a credit card
to pay for your online purchases your
transaction is protected by the fair
credit billing act which
means you can dispute any charges under
certain circumstances
i'm kiersten joints